un asesinato masivo selectivo contra su
propio pueblo la junta militar de
myanmar ha confirmado que llevó a cabo
un ataque aéreo contra este lugar su
portavoz declaró a la televisión militar
que se trató de una operación de
seguridad destinada a restablecer la paz
y la estabilidad en la región
Sí por supuesto lanzamos el ataque
contra Ellos
nos informaron que miembros de las
fuerzas de defensa del pueblo murieron
durante el ataque aéreo
la junta afirma que el ataque en el
municipio de cambalo tenía como objetivo
una ceremonia de inauguración de una
oficina local organizada por las fdp el
brazo armado del gobierno de unidad
nacional formado por un grupo de
legisladores electos expulsados en el
golpe de estado de febrero de 2021
mostrando estas fotos los militares
culparon de las víctimas civiles a
personas obligadas a ayudar a los
terroristas también afirmaron que
miembros de las fdp estaban cometiendo
crímenes de guerra y a contra la
población local testigos afirman que
aviones militares lanzaron bombas
directamente sobre una multitud matando
a docenas entre ellos muchos niños las
Naciones Unidas y el gobierno
estadounidense han condenado la acción
militar la junta de myanmar recurre cada
vez más a los ataques aéreos para
contrarrestar la lucha armada contra su
gobierno alegando que combate el
terrorismo se calcula que más de 3000
civiles han muerto desde que los
generales del ejército arrebataron el
poder al gobierno civil dirigido por
antsan Sushi la ONU Calcula que
alrededor de 1,2 millones de personas se
han visto obligadas a abandonar sus
hogares